il est 17h30 environ ce samedi 13
février quand des policiers sont pris à
partie quartier beauregard à poissy par
une trentaine d'individus venus
dissoudre un attroupement ils reçoivent
projectiles et insultes on peut
constater que sur la même après-midi
il ya eu des événements aussi aux
mureaux et à sartrouville
les collègues sont malheureusement
habitués à ce phénomène à l'individu de
sont de plus en plus violent et
déterminé et nous malheureusement les
sanctions pénales ne suivent pas et pas
non plus notre travail c'est de les
protéger
les protégés par la loi les protégés par
du matériel et d'efforts supplémentaires
et des protégés aussi par l'intervention
de la police et gendarmerie j'ai appelé
le maire de poissy ce week end julie à
quel point évidemment la police
nationale étaient à la disposition de la
république pour pouvoir maintenir
l'ordre dans sa commune l équipage de la
police nationale réplique avec des gaz
lacrymogènes et un tir de l'elbe et dès
l'acte est qualifié d' intolérable par
la vie qui appelle au calme une grosse
frustration parce que la ville de
possibles multiplient encore une fois
l'accompagnement multiplie les
initiatives en direction de l'ensemble
des jeunes de la ville de poissy sans
aucune exclusive et je crois que les
jeunes l'ont bien compris tu es vraiment
l'incompréhension qu'on peut analyser
que par de la provocation
la deuxième chose c'est la colère est la
mairie indique par communiqué que les
acteurs de terrain vont se réunir dans
la semaine avec la préfecture